-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, let's get to some news.
Well, guys, for everyone
invested in our country's banks,
March Madness has begun.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, a lot of people are talking
about this.
Over the weekend, the U.S.
economy was rocked
after the Silicon Valley bank
crashed,
becoming the second largest bank
failure in U.S. history.
It's never good when people who
are watching CNBC are shrieking
louder than the people watching
"Scream VI."
They're like, "Oh! Ah!"
Silicon Valley bank knew they
were in trouble when they saw
themselves in the Oscars
In Memoriam.
They go, "Oh, that's us."
On the bright side, it was
refreshing to hear about a crash
that had nothing to do
with a self-driving Tesla.
Don't you think?
In response to the crash, today,
President Biden delivered
a speech and ensured Americans
they can have confidence
that the banking system is safe.
Hearing from Biden actually did
make me feel better
because you know if it were
really bad, he would've been
like, "Kamala,
you take this one."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You did this one."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Biden tried to put everyone
at ease.
He said, "Don't worry.
I got through the first
Great Depression.
I'll get through this one."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meanwhile, in response, Trump
said, "It's times like these
where we need a president
with experience
of multiple bankruptcies.
And that's --"
That's where I'm --"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, some sports news.
Everyone's excited about this.
Yesterday was Selection Sunday,
where they announce the 68 teams
in this year's March Madness
tournament.
Yep.
That's exciting.
That's right.
It starts at 68, then 32,
then eventually down to 1,
just like the number
of U.S. banks.
And, yeah, first Oscar pools,
and now brackets --
it's that time of year when we
lose money to coworkers
we've never heard of before.
It's like, "Who the hell is
Graham? I owe Graham $20."
Well, March Madness is about
to begin.
There's so many great teams
this year.
Kansas, Purdue, Gonzaga --
is it Gonzaga or Gonzaga?
I'm always forgetting how
they're pronounced.
-Oh, come on. Come on.
If you're going to talk about
the tournament, you've got to
know how to pronounce the names,
you know what I mean?
-Oh, so you know how to
pronounce all this year's
men's basketball teams?
-Not only that,
I know how to pronounce every
college basketball team.
I'm an announcer.
Kind of my job.
So, go ahead.
Test me, give me some names.
-Give you some names --
all right, I guess I can
test you real quick.
Okay, what is this?
What school is this?
-Oh, come on.
Corn hole. Easy.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, how about this one?
How about this one?
-"Vanderpump Rules."
Come on, give me a hard one.
[ Laughter ]
Rapid fire me.
-You want rapid fire?
All right, here we go.
Here we go. What's this?
-Okay. USB Cord.
Charleton Heston.
Mary Jane.
Burning Man.
Liposuction.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, "Miss, I pee pee great."
Viagra.
Prepubescence.
Stormy Daniel's book.
Dookie.
Oral sex robot.
[ Laughter ]
Sweet boning adventure.
Oh, oh, this is Ken's ass.
Oh, vagina.
West vagina.
Penis taint.
Oh, I can't even believe you can
say this on TV.
Ball state.
-Okay, that's enough.
Thank you.
You're right. You're right.
You know how to pronounce them
all.
Steve Higgins, everybody.
Steve Higgins.
Sorry about that, yeah.
Well, some big
entertainment news.
Last night was
the 95th Academy Awards.
And I want to say congrats
to all the winners.
"Everything Everywhere
All At Once" had a huge night,
taking home seven awards.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Meanwhile, the Oscars were on at
the same time
as the season finale
of "The Last of Us,"
and you could tell people
were a little distracted.
Check this out.
-It is my honor to be named
alongside you in this category.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You don't have to tell me all
of this.
-Yeah, I actually do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They had two --
They had two camera angles.
-Yeah, two camera angles.
There was a guy right over
his shoulder, yeah.
-Yeah, exactly.
Some more business news,
I heard that Apple is working
on AirPods that can improve
your hearing,
monitor your posture,
and take your temperature.
Take your temperature?
People are like,
"Exactly where am I supposed to
put these things?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Pops lips ]
Oh, my posture is better.
-No!
-Wow.
Well, according to a new study,
for the first time in decades,
IQ scores in the U.S.
have fallen.
I think that might be true.
Take a look at this recent
episode of "Jeopardy!" I saw.
Kris Anne.
-What is "Free Willy?"
-No.
Brad?
-Who is Stanley Tucci?
-No.
-Reuben?
-What's a suitcase?
-No.
-Who is Princess Peach?
Sam?
-What is pine tar?
-No.
-Stephen.
-What is the whole enchilada?
-No.
Jason?
-What's the Leaning Tower
of Pisa.
-No.
-What are hot dogs?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Way off. Way off.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, a man in Illinois
is suing Buffalo Wild Wings
because he claims their boneless
wings are just chicken nuggets.
[ Laughter ]
Buffalo Wild Wings was like,
"Congrats, you're the first
person sober enough to notice."
Yeah.